there are times when IM setsuna's
mimicry is too obvious for its own good
when you immediately recognize that it's
a deliberate effort to trigger nostalgia
for classic Japanese RPGs but these
moments don't tell the whole story
poignant events lend distinction to the
otherwise archetypal cast and you grew
to appreciate how tenets of the genre
are ignored in favor of trying something
new the juxtaposition of item sets in
his numerous inventions and references
make for an eye-opening examination of
Japanese RPGs and a satisfactory debut
from developer Tokyo RPG Factory
in a world blanketed with snow and
overridden with beasts young setsuna
sets out to reach the last lands it is
there that she will fulfill her duty as
a human sacrifice a ritual held every
decade to keep wild threats at bay with
the help of like-minded adventurers you
accompany setsuna through caverns and
forests fending off creatures and
fording or recruiting humans that try to
stand in your way
can easy
setsuna would be the first person to
admit that her fate is tragic but she
remains steadfast and resolute in her
charge you can say the same for her
companions some of whom face very
different but equally somber realities
with grace clocking in around 20 hours
moderately short by RPG standards it's
unfortunate that I am setsuna doesn't
allow more time for backstory and
character development the majority of
your venture is spent in combat which is
almost identical to chrono triggers
battle system and thankfully every bit
is enjoyable
there are no random encounters and I am
setsuna battles begin when you bump into
enemies visible in dungeons
there are no enemies on the world map
and there are two ways to approach
combat active mode or wait mode active
mode allows ATB gauges to fill on a
constant basis when that gauge is full
that ally or enemy can make a move if
you choose to play in weight mode all
ETB gauges stop charging when you're
picking an action from the command menu
affording you more time to plan your
next move every character has an
inherent strength weapon type and
selection of skills known as Tex techs
are a product of things called sprite
night magical stones that are slotted
into equipment certain characters can
combine text in combat to dish out a
devastating attack or a powered up
recovery spell so long as they both have
full atv gauges with a limited number of
slots for sprite night you have to
carefully pick and choose which text to
carry not only to have a well-rounded
team but to ensure the availability of
prefered combo attacks which are
strictly tied to specific text every
tech can be enhanced on-the-fly during
combat when a character builds up enough
SP to trigger momentum which requires
you to press a button immediately after
a flash of light during the character's
wind-up animation you earn SP when you
attack and you take damage and if you
wait when it's your turn to move
managing momentum opportunities is the
most critical element during fights as
it can in effect turn one action into to
exhume in typical RPG fashion characters
are an experience from combat and level
up but rather than impact every stat new
levels only boost a character's hit
points and magic points instead weapons
dictated characters physical and magical
strength as well as both types of
defense
therefore purchasing weapons becomes a
habit the moment you discover a new town
but you can't buy anything in IM setsuna
until you sell materials objects earned
in battle and found on the ground when
exploring dungeons because currency
isn't dulled out after fights or found
in treasure chests the reliance on
materials for currency and skills feels
different from most other RPGs as
perhaps the most resounding invention in
the game designed to be almost wholly
referential
by the end of volume sets enough mobs of
common enemies albeit strong ones can't
stand up to a well-oiled party and can
be wiped out with a single combo move
and a little added momentum as such it
can feel like you're going through the
motions at times when playing I am
setsuna this paired with obvious
references to well-known games can make
the experience feel rote and at worst
boring so I am setsuna is an
unapologetic homage to beloved Japanese
RPGs that plays well and takes few risks
Tokyo RPG Factory has accomplished their
implied mission statement to make
Japanese RPGs the way many of us
remember them back in the day as someone
who grew up playing these games I
enjoyed my time with i''m sets enough it
was nice to look back and remember the
good times